yes it's still too early to say for sure
but you
admitted that Egghead as Quirky as its
name may be has all the right
ingredients to become the most unique
and impactful story arc in all of One
Piece why well if you make it to the end
of this video you will find out how Vega
Punk is connected to each and every one
of the straw hats what Luffy's reunion
with Luchi and seraphim Kuma actually
means and what the name of each of the
vegapung6 Clones tells us about their
role in this Arc let's find out why
Egghead Island stands out as possibly
the strangest and quirkiest Island in a
story that is famous for strange and
quirky Islands there's a candy Island a
Dinosaur Island an Angel Island in the
sky a mermaid Island down in the ocean
and a samurai Island on top of the ocean
I mean you get what I'm saying at this
point however what already makes Egghead
stand out from this list is that it
seems to be connected to almost each and
every one of the places I just listed
and that's of course because this island
that said to be 500 years in the future
is the home of probably the most
mysterious and anticipated character in
the entire story with of course the sole
exception of a certain red-haired pirate
so I wouldn't be too surprised if he
made another surprise appearance in this
Arc as well maybe birds back to the
story Dr vegapunk Who apparently has
been too busy doing science stuff to get
a proper professor's degree at this
point is a character that knows more
about the world than any other character
outside maybe the godosei and maybe the
remaining Roger Pirates probably he
knows even more now no matter if
vegapunk is someone from the void
Century but time traveler or even
someone from another planet what's
important right now is that he's
possibly the only person in the world
who has unlocked the secrets of the
devil fruits whoever they are they
clearly know a ton about the true
history and nature of the one piece
World given that they also researched
dragons and Ancient Giants two groups of
creatures that were officially once part
of this planet some distant point in the
past and that's a point that I think has
now only been proven more by the
appearance of zp0 who have been tasked
with assassinating the government's most
valuable asset huh why would the guru
say or emu issue such an order fearing
that vegapunk knows too much of the
truth well if they didn't have at least
some sort of concrete proof that they do
I mean yes admittedly usually the
government doesn't hesitate really to
take someone out on the pure suspicion
that they could a one percent chance
that they could know something that he
or she shouldn't but this is their
prized genius scientist that we're
talking about that has enabled them to
rule as securely as they have through
their Innovations and so to bring it
back to my original Point vegapunk's
Innovations are found throughout the
entire world and have accompanied the
straw hats Journey as far back as
Alabaster where they encounter a cannon
that has in a Zone devil fruit just to
really Hammer this point home for you
the very first hint at this character
that is now revealed and this island has
been dropped almost 900 chapters ago
which undoubtedly makes vegapunk one of
the core elements of one piece that each
year order had planned right from the
beginning just to quickly walk you
through it we have another object devil
fruit on in this Lobby the sea Stone
covered ships of the Marines that allows
them to pass through the combat unharmed
nami's climb attack that with its
weather X strongly resembles the overall
island of Egghead as a concept The Giant
Egg on the island basically deserves as
a giant terraforming version of that
same technology that conveniently you
know also can be used as a giant
research facility for all of vegapunks
quite a space intense Enterprises let's
put it that way later on we ran into a
bunch of biological experiments like
bigger punks failed dragons on Punk
Hazard or his research into
gigantification they were able to
successfully duplicate one of the most
powerful devil fruits in existence with
kaido's mythical dragon fruit and maybe
the most successful of all his
experiments was the research he did in
collaboration with judge Vin smoke that
resulted in the creation of our all
favorite cook Sanji and his siblings who
do have unparalleled at really strange
Powers a power by the way that might
have also played a decisive role in the
creation of the six clones of vegapunk
we see in this chapter and who I will
analyze for you based on their names and
attributes in just a bit because most
impactful for the one piece world where
of course all his military projects that
almost meant the end for the straw hat
crew on Saba ODI using his discovery of
the lineage factor in Devil fruits that
also seem to connect with the mythical
lunarian race somehow Vega Punk not only
turned the warlord Bartholomew Kuma into
a cyborg cloned him but he also equipped
him with the abilities of Admiral
kizaru's pika pika fruit light powers
and quite recent telling the story Vega
Punk has finished the development of the
so-called seraphim replicas of all the
former Warlords with even greater Powers
than their predecessor the pacifista now
this new weapon was not only strong
enough to replace the existing warlord
system completely as you know but the
government even sent one of the Sarah
theme with zp0 to take out their Maker
Now do I think that that was a
particularly smart move no no I really
don't I think that if vegapunk is only
half as smart as Oda makes him out to be
then they probably saw that betrayal of
the government coming from miles away
and have taken precautions against that
and if you're asking me whether or not I
believe that vegapunk will end up
becoming an ally to the straw hats by
the end of this Arc but I'm getting
ahead of myself here I'm going to talk
about zp0 and why luchi's appearance is
the best thing that could have happened
to this Arc if you make it to the end of
this video it actually doesn't really
matter if Vega Punk will be the Ally or
the villain of the this Arc like as
we'll discuss in just a bit they might
well turn out to be both my point here
is that Dr vegapunk has been
accompanying us throughout the entirety
of the grand line and I really think
it's no coincidence that they have
connections to almost all the straw hats
let me organize them in order of most to
least important for you first off there
is Frankie now Frankie is not only a
cyborg himself and the second most
technologically advanced character in
one piece after begapunk but he also has
spent a whole two years during the time
skip in vegapunk's Old lab studying all
of his work these two will have a lot to
talk about and hopefully Frankie will
leave the island with an upgrade or two
and a ton of fresh technical knowledge
as well I mean just look at all the
gadgets that we've already seen here
giant robots and monsters Holograms food
making machines a lot of stuff that
looks suspiciously like space technology
at the very least I want to see Frankie
leave with a larger Shogun Frankie
version than Vega punks then there is
Sanji who has mentioned kind of is the
result of vegapung's research himself in
a way I really do hope that we get to
see some more explanation of sanji's
true Powers at worst and an upgrade to
those Powers at best so we saw in Nami
are connected to them through the
climate act which hopefully also will
receive a major upgrade during this Arc
as well then we have Chopper who is
looking to become the best doctor in the
world and that can cure any disease and
if a science lab 500 years in the future
is not the best place for that I really
don't know what would be then we have
our captain Luffy who still doesn't know
the true identity of his own devil fruit
now in general I'm convinced that this
is going to be the Arc in which we're
going to learn almost everything if not
actually everything there is to know
about devil fruits and their secrets and
I'm pretty sure that vegapunk is the
right person to teach Luffy the true
name of his Nika fruit and what those
powers are truly capable off now this is
not a straw hat but we also have to talk
of course about vegapunk's connection to
jewelry Bonnie who it turns out is
Kuma's daughter after all and who has
been to this island before as a child
now correct me if I'm wrong if Kuma was
a king I guess that technically makes
Bonnie the coolest princess in any Arc
so far no offense to any VB fans of
course out there but still you know and
then we have of course Zorro who at
first glance might not seem to have any
relationship with vegapunk but I'm just
gonna put it out there and pray that
it'll come true I want to see one of
Zorro's swords eat a devil fruit there I
said it it's out there now if you also
want to see that happen well make sure
to hit the Subscribe button because
otherwise it definitely won't but wait a
minute this is like still the beginning
of why eckhead could be the best Arc one
piece has ever seen like you see how
much longer is left in this video like
this is only half the story what's crazy
is what I want to talk about next
because while we all thought that Mega
Punk is just one old dude with a
mustache Well turns out that they went
full six paths of pain and created six
other sentient versions of himself that
all function independently like they're
all their own people like what and this
is where this all gets very very juicy
you see it's really interesting how much
information we can already extract about
Mega Punk and all of his six pass from
just one panel where we got showing how
they're all organized so first of all we
do get confirmation that there is the
actual original body of Dr vegapunk
that's still alive he didn't just go and
split himself into six parts no there is
still the old version as well now do I
think that it's gonna be a cliche bold
old man with white lab coat and mustache
after all it's possible but I prefer the
original Vega Punk to be more of a let's
say surprise maybe a non-human character
or a character we've already met
somewhere in the story that we totally
thought was unimportant or or how about
the theory that vegapunk is actually a
time traveled version of Frankie you
know what I'm just gonna let myself be
surprised by whatever it's gonna be we
do know a bit more however about
vegapung6 alter egos so this is how it
works each of the six has a number
ranking from one to six this might turn
out to be false later on but it seems to
me like there is actually some sort of
hierarchy in this ranking after all we
do see number two taking orders from
number one about not underestimating the
straw hats and bringing them to him then
each of the six is also assigned a kanji
that seems to describe their personality
in some way a form we have Justice evil
thoughtfulness wisdom violence and
desire and finally each of the six also
has a unique name based on a real or
mythical character from our world
there's Shaka Lilith Edison Pythagoras
tagaras photographs Atlas and York and
these names together with each of their
attributes tells us actually quite a lot
about them so let's start with number
one Justice Shaka as far as I can tell
this version of vegapunk is based on
Shaka Zulu who was the King of the Zulu
Kingdom from 1816 to 1828 a legendary
and quite controversial ruler he
instituted wide-reaching reforms and
innovations that turned the Zulu
military into a quite terrifying force
and at the end he was ultimately
assassinated by his two half-brothers
now this is super interesting already
now I think as we'll get more clear as
we go through each of these six version
to me it seems that based on their
inspiration each of them might be
responsible for different inventions
credited to vegapunk and I do think that
number one seems to be a prime candidate
for the one who created the Posse fista
and the seraphim I mean he is number one
and the fact that he has the kanji for
justice also puts him quite close to the
Marines and the government plus the
entire military invention thing and who
knows could him being killed by two of
his half-brothers hint at a conflict
between the different versions of
vegapunk like just imagine how cool that
would be some siding with the straw hats
and some siding with the governments
heck maybe there is just one Vega Punk
among the existing six who is actually
in cahoots with the revolutionaries see
that's why I say that this Arc has the
potential to be something else entirely
okay so then we have number two the evil
Lilith the verse version of vegapunk we
have seen the most of so far and who
does come across a bit evil in the
interactions she's had so far now Lilith
is the only Vega punk I think not based
on a real person as far as I can tell
but on the legend of Lilith a female
figure in Mesopotamian and judaic
mythology who's said to be the first
wife of Adam before Eve and becoming the
first primordial demon after being
banished from the Garden of Eden for him
not obeying at again absolutely love the
characters that Oda chose here they are
all super fascinating by themselves
already I think Lilith as the demon
archetype is basically the one who
created anything monster related like
the dragons or the army of sea kings
that we see her summon and she has a
pretty awesome design too I must say so
uh let's just wait and see how evil she
really turns out to be number three the
thoughtful Edison now this one you
probably figured out yourself this
vegapunk surely must be based on Thomas
Edison the American inventor who
developed a ton of devices in fields
such as electric power generation mass
communication sound recording and Motion
Pictures in other words his inventions
which include the phonograph the motion
picture camera and early versions of the
electric light bulb have had a
widespread impact on the entire modern
industrialized worlds now to me this
kind of sounds like the most civilized
version of vegapunku you know who most
likely came up with a lot of awesome
Technologies like the Hologram we see or
the denden Mushi harmless but extremely
useful innovations that benefit the
world in short now number four is the
wise Pythagoras you might remember his
theorem from high school however if you
now think that's boring and that all he
did was math you're very wrong because
Pythagoras is actually most famous for
his Madam psychosis or the
transmigration of souls I thought I
might get your attention with that now
Pythagoras thought that every soul is
Immortal and upon death enters into a
new body just like the devil fruits plus
he did a bunch of astronomy like proving
that the Earth is round sorry flat
earthers and the identity of the morning
and evening Stars being the planet Venus
oh yeah and he was also the first one to
divide the globe into five different
climatic zones now there is a bunch of
stuff in there that we can relate to Dr
begapong's research as you probably
noticed anything climate related like
the climate Act and the weather X there
might be some space science hinted at
there as well but most interesting right
now I think is the idea of
transmigration of souls now this for me
suggests that this is the version of
Mega Punk that might be responsible for
all the devil fruit related research
including the lineage factor and feeding
devil fruits to objects next up is
number five which is violence Atlas now
just a few moments ago I said that
Lilith was the only mythological
character but now that I think about it
that was clearly wrong because Atlas was
one of the Titans that fought a great
war against the Greek gods and when the
Titans were defeated by the gods many of
them were banished to Tartarus but Zeus
condemned Atlas to stand at the western
edge of the Earth and hold up the sky on
his shoulders and I do actually find
this a really interesting choice here I
really wonder what atlas's role might be
in the context of vegapunk my best guess
would be that since she's a Titan and
pretty big herself she might be the one
who is responsible for the research into
gigantification and The Ancient Giants
that we've seen you know like for
example the numbers and then we have
number six desire York now this one I'm
really not quite sure who Oda is trying
to base them on my best guess would be
York the American explorer who was the
only black member of the Lewis and Clark
expedition not really sure what his
field of research then might be in the
context of One Piece exploring the one
piece World maybe I mean if Oda wanted
to go down that route number six
vegapunk might look very much like a set
of female King like a lunarian given
that the historical York was also black
you know similar to how number five
Atlas who is based on a Titan is huge or
how Lilith based on the woman is a woman
really unsure with this one but that's
my best guess so far but we're not done
yet because we saved desserts for last
because cp0 has just joined the chat and
fun fact they have been in four arcs in
a row now with the only exception being
zo Andres Rosa whole cake Island wano
and now Egghead that's some really bad
luck they have running into the straw
hats every single time but the fact that
we finally get to see a reunion and
possibly a rematch between Luffy and
Lucci I mean I really love Yoda for
doing this I'm really really excited
that it feels like this Arc is kind of
going to be the opposite to 108 small
island with only a handful of characters
but boy the stakes are just as high the
government coming with some of their
strongest Fighters the straw hats Bonnie
being the princess and vegapunk and
their clones kind of torn between the
government that has betrayed them and
the future pirate king I mean dude just
think of all the lore and the secrets
that we'll get to explore during this
Arc it's actually kind of hard to keep
track of all the questions that we could
get answers to from vegapunk luckily I
made a video about just that so watch
that here if you like